JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello, and
welcome to "YouTube Developers
Live." We have an exciting
show for you today.
In this studio, I have
Jeremy Walker.
JEREMY WALKER: Hello.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How are
you doing, Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: I'm doing well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Long
time, no see, man.
JEREMY WALKER: I know.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And I am very
happy to tell you that we
have exciting guests coming
from far today.
We have Tim Wintle.
TIM WINTLE: Hi.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How
are you doing, Tim?
TIM WINTLE: Yeah.
I'm very well.
Thanks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Where are
you visiting us from?
TIM WINTLE: I've flown
in from the UK.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
And Matias Molinas.
MATIAS MOLINAS: Hi.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How are
you doing, Matias?
MATIAS MOLINAS: Fine.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And
where are you from?
MATIAS MOLINAS: From
Argentina.
From Latin America.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So this is going to be
an exciting show.
What we wanted to cover is tell
you a little bit about
our Google Developer Expert
Program and then chat with Tim
and Matias about their
experience with YouTube APIs
as well as tell us a little bit
more about the community
in the UK and Argentina,
respectively.
So let's get into it.
Some of you might have heard
about our Google Developers
Expert Program, and I'm very
proud to announce that we have
two developer experts right
now for YouTube APIs.
We're looking for more, so if
you're excited about YouTube
API, please get in touch.
And why don't we start
with you, Tim.
So Tim, you mentioned you
are from the UK, right?
TIM WINTLE: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And how
did you get started
with YouTube APIs?
TIM WINTLE: So we initially--
I needed to collect data around
kind of how much videos
had been viewed and all kind
of information around it.
And we kind of looked at
scraping YouTube, which
quickly we discovered in terms
of service kind of say, you
can't do that.
And so eventually, we found
the APIs, and I started
looking at that.
And then I just found the groups
and ended up posting
quite a lot on there.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And was that
a site project or was it a
work project?
TIM WINTLE: It is actually
a research project.
We got funding.
It was kind of working
with the same
company I work at now.
Well, in fact, it's developed
into that company.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: What
do you do for work?
TIM WINTLE: So I work at an
ad network called Viral Ad
Network in the UK.
We have a lot of kind of YouTube
content that we put
out through our ad network.
And we kind of track engagement
with us and we use
the Player API a lot to
make sure that we know
what's going on.
And we do some custom builds for
ads and things like that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool
About you, Matias.
What got you into
YouTube APIs?
MATIAS MOLINAS: Well, I
am GDG organizer tool.
So I begin to make some session
about the YouTube APIs.
And I have my company tool.
And I've been to working out on
my own product that I use
YouTube API v3 experimental
away.
And I made two open-source
projects.
And I try to provide session
with different kind of
articles, and projects
in my situation.
So this is the way that I've
come to use the API.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And you
mentioned you also involved in
the Google Developers,
group community.
Which city?
MATIAS MOLINAS: In Santa
Fe and in Argentina.
We have several GDG groups
in Argentina and
in all South America.
Well, I work with the GDGs from
another service and in
other countries from
Latin America.
While I made sessions in Santa
Fe or via Hangout in another
city or in other countries, I
talk about the YouTube API.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And Tim, back to you.
Where in UK do you live?
TIM WINTLE: So I actually live
in the Northwest now.
When I first started working
with YouTube, I was living in
the southwest.
And so I've kind
of moved about.
I think there is a local sort of
Google Developer Group that
used to be in Gita, but I've not
managed to make it there.
And it's not quite made
it across to--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
TIM WINTLE: --to the UK or
has not become big like
it is in the US.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Great.
Well, we'll fix that.
So a couple of questions
about your personal
preferences, if I may.
So what's your favorite
programming language?
TIM WINTLE: I work
in Python a lot.
I like dynamic languages, so
yeah, I use a lot of Python,
and C, and JavaScript.
C is obviously the one that
stands out differently.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
I rarely see Python
and C and dynamic
languages in the same sentence.
But--
TIM WINTLE: You can do object
orientated C. You just need to
have standards for it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And I guess in
Python, it's pretty common
to build libraries and
then wrap them in
Python code, right?
TIM WINTLE: Yeah.
And just optimize the kind of
just the loops that really
need to be optimized instead
of writing the
whole thing in C++.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And are you a
client library guy or do you
prefer use REST APIs directly?
TIM WINTLE: So since if you've
been following the YouTube
APIs, it's kind of all
gone to OAuth 2.0.
Since OAuth 2.0 came out, I've
started using the client
libraries, because you
kind of have to.
It's very difficult not to.
But before that, I was making
the REST requests myself and
doing auths and stuff.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: With
client login.
TIM WINTLE: Sometimes, yeah,
which you shouldn't use now as
we've been hosting a lot.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Definitely.
OAuth is the way to go.
TIM WINTLE: But actually,
there's a few ways that aren't
quite documented,
if you'd like.
If you look at some of the demo
apps that have come out
for the v3 API, they kind of--
they get around some of the
automatic spec for the library
that gets downloaded.
And they make the kind of input
in the endpoint URL, and
it just handles the
auth for you.
And you can manage this just
at a slightly lower level.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
TIM WINTLE: And that's really
useful if you need to kind of
wrap all of your HTTP requests
if you're doing offline stuff
or that kind of--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: It sounds like
an interesting blog post
article for those resisting
client libraries, and yet they
don't want to deal with OAuth.
TIM WINTLE: Yeah.
Cool.
And how you, Matias?
What's your favorite programming
language?
MATIAS MOLINAS: I like Java,
JavaScript, and maybe C# too.
But this is maybe my core
set of language.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
MATIAS MOLINAS: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Very good
set for service-side and
client-side development.
And what about client
libraries.
Do you like them or do you
prefer to parse based on XML?
MATIAS MOLINAS: I prefer to do
the codes directly and parse
the result.
So I have more control
in this way.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
MATIAS MOLINAS: And I
like have control.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, I see.
Interesting.
Well, we are learning
a lot about your
character in this interview.
All right.
So real men use REST directly.
Right?
Is that?
Cool.
So I know Jeremy wanted to ask
you a few questions about some
of the new APIs.
So Jeremy, over to you.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
Great.
So of course, I usually
like to focus on
the three main APIs.
You have the player and a couple
of ones that we have
that I wanted to talk to you
guys a little bit about.
So the first one would be the
Data API or version 3.
So for you that don't know,
we've had an experimental
stage for this API, and it's
kind of a complete
rewrite of version 2.
And there's a lot of new
features we've added, and it's
all Jason based, and it's
much more you just
get what you need.
So it's a lot more lighter
and a lot more efficient.
So I wanted to talk to you guys
a little bit about that
to see if you've used it a
little bit and tell us about
what you've done.
TIM WINTLE: I used this new
API, and I like the
integration with the Freebase
and the possibility that you
can search videos using Freebase
Topics, because I
think that this a very
powerful feature.
It's a key feature if you want
to make, for example,
recommendation system, you can
access this from a playlist
from the user.
And your can retrieve the
different Freebase topics that
related to the videos that the
user what like, or maybe
provide the videos, or maybe the
videos that the user want
to watch later.
So you have a very good source
for recommendations.
I think that the Explorer, the
Topic Explorer sample is a
very good application tool
to begin to use this API.
In fact, I use this project to
learn the YouTube API v3.
And I recommend to all the
people to use and to test this
application.
JEREMY WALKER: We will tell our
colleague Jeffrey Posnick
that you like it.
MATIAS MOLINAS: Yeah.
I like this application.
TIM WINTLE: And that
actually uses that
method as I was saying.
I think this is documented under
the General GAPI API
that you can just make
these requests
outside of the main flow.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
And for those out, there the
Topics API, what you do is
semantic search and it's based
on Freebase like you were
talking about.
And that's one of the
big features.
It's just a way that you can
search terms that may have
multiple meanings and get
the exact version.
We have a talk on it, so be
sure to check that out.
So I'm assuming then you didn't
use, from what you were
saying earlier, you didn't use
the Java client library then.
You just used server?
MATIAS MOLINAS: I used the
AngularJS and JavaScript to
test the API because I
discovered AngularJS with the
Topic Explorer.
And I like AngularJS.
And I like JavaScript, so I use
the YouTube API v3 with
JavaScript.
JEREMY WALKER: So was there
anything that you ran into
that kind of surprise you at all
about using the API that
you weren't expecting?
MATIAS MOLINAS: No.
I think that another thing I
like is the API, you can use
the API in the same
way that you use
another APIs from Google.
For example, I use the
Provision API tool.
And I use the same libraries,
and the same clients, and the
same optimization system.
So really, this is the I life
from YouTube API v3.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
Building it on the same
architecture plug-in, it makes
it easy to switch between them
if you need to pick up some
extra APIs to use with
your product.
So yeah, I totally agree
with that one.
MATIAS MOLINAS: And you can
use the same tools.
You can use the API Explorer
to test the different codes
and this is very productive.
You are the developer, you don't
need to learn a lot of
tools or a lot of client
libraries.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
The API Explorer is a big
thing for me too.
For those who don't know, it's
right below our docs.
We have this little like
interactive thing where you
can kind of fill out forms of
what you kind of want, and it
puts together dynamically the
requests that goes out, the
restore request, the
HTTP request that
goes out to our system.
And it shows the response down
below so you can start editing
stuff directly.
And I'm sure that's really
useful, especially if you're
not necessarily using the client
libraries, because then
you can see exactly what you're
looking for and make
sure it's right before you even
try starting to integrate
it into your app.
Great.
Well, let's talk a little bit
about the Player and the
Analytics API because I know
you use that quite a bit.
TIM WINTLE: Yeah.
JEREMY WALKER: So why don't we
start with the Player API, and
for you out there, that's
just a way to play
back videos off YouTube.
I'm assuming you use
the IFrame embed.
TIM WINTLE: Well actually, I use
most of the Player APIs so
there's an old-style
JavaScript API.
There's two Flash APIs, although
there's one of them--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: S2.
S3.
TIM WINTLE: Yeah, is S2.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
It's still there.
TIM WINTLE: And there's the
IFrame API which allows HTML5
playback on mobile, which is
particularly useful, which is
now a full, it's not
experimental.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
No longer experimental.
TIM WINTLE: So yeah.
I kind of a switch between
them depending on
what I need to do.
And I try to avoid Flash, but
sometimes you've got a big
Flash movie, and you need
a video in there.
JEREMY WALKER: And I'm
suspecting a lot with ads, you
have some ads that you've
constructed like you're saying
using the AS3, probably, player
within those ads, so
you need access to that.
TIM WINTLE: So actually, a lot
of our stuff is pulling off
the kind of events that
come back from them.
And luckily, there are all
fairly similar in what events
they give, they throw it in
slightly different ways, so
like the IFrame API looks more
like a DOM event, that's
bubbling compared to the
ActionScript APIs.
But, yes.
So that's the kind of
main stuff we use.
We try not to use the playVideo
method and stuff
like that because people don't
realize that normally doesn't
count as a view on YouTube.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
The playback has to be user
generated, user initiated in
order to count.
TIM WINTLE: Yeah.
That's something I think a lot
of people don't realize when
they first start
looking at it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That's true.
But it makes a lot of sense.
It's really good to see that
kind of people can't abuse the
API in that way.
JEREMY WALKER: Was there
anything that, I guess,
surprised you when you were
using the Player APIs or was
it pretty straightforward?
TIM WINTLE: So once you've got
the skeleton code there, it's
fairly easy.
I think it's more inheritance
in JavaScript.
There are kind of several
different callbacks.
So there's a callback once the
script is being inserted into
the IFrame API.
And then there's another
callback once the Player has
been instantiated.
And like I see a lot of
confusion coming from kind of
if someone else is reading my
code and they're not used to
the APIs, there's kind of like
at what point is this a Player
instance, and at what point
is this a global setting.
But once you've got that kind
of done, it just works.
And this is really good,
especially now that there's
kind of mobile support, and you
can actually play videos
on mobile using this API in the
same way you would on any
other platform.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think the
API platform life cycle in a
very asynchronous system
is always a challenge.
But I think the team has kind
of evolved over the years to
what it is.
TIM WINTLE: The other thing that
they made quite a kind of
clean-cut decision when they
made the IFrame API into not
supporting any browsers that
don't have the postMessage
API, which is post HTML5.
Which kind of means that IE8 and
Quirks load doesn't work
and anything below that works, I
think IE8 and Standards load
should work rather than INI.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
You find this an
issue for your clients?
TIM WINTLE: So I've actually I
have a kind of general rapid
assign insert that detects if
there's a postMessage, and if
there is, it uses the
IFrame embed.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
TIM WINTLE: And if there's not,
then it drops in the old
JavaScript API to the Flash.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
I think the motivation there
was really with a
proliferation of
mobile devices.
This is where when you get
something that would work
across different platforms,
and that is a very good
interface to use for some of the
mobile platforms as well.
TIM WINTLE: It's a very clean
API, and this will be, well, a
lot of people aren't
supporting IE8 now.
And by this time next year, I
think I'll have removed all of
the code that kind of deals
with, if you haven't got it.
So yeah.
I'm very glad this kind of a
clean cut and not trying to
support everything
indefinitely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So sometimes
inflicting a little bit of
pain pays off in the long run.
TIM WINTLE: Yeah.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, I also, now you use the
Insight, which for you that
don't know, Insight is kind of
the, it's part of version 2,
so the older data API that
lets you pull analytics
information.
And we have a new Analytics API
that is in experimental
mode right now that a lot of
people are playing with.
So I was going to ask you like,
just a quick overview
like what you thought of that
and if you've seen any
benefits to all the data you're
pulling now with Insight.
TIM WINTLE: So yeah.
The biggest thing is that the
old Insight API just kind of
gave you like almost a
[? toggle ?] or a zip file
with a big CSV with columns.
And the columns used to change
as more data was added.
And you had to kind of download,
then store this all
in RAM, extract it.
And yeah, it was messy.
So one of the biggest
things is you don't
need to do that anymore.
It's more like a kind
of query language.
So it's a really clean kind of
service-orientated query that
you can just make as though you
were querying a database.
And you could also
query right back.
So you're not kind of limited
to just the last I think it
was 14 days, it could have been
30 days that you could
query before you can actually
get loads of data going back.
Plus there's all of the new
stuff like Average Freelance.
And I'm hoping that it's
going to be expanding
more and more before--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think
metrics is what you're
referring to.
And definitely, we are always
pushing the team, Jeremy, to
expose more of these metrics.
And I think they've done a good
job catching up with what
we have available
on YouTube.com.
And that's really the goal is
to expose as much as we can
through the new API as opposed
to the Insight API.
So I think for folks that are
still using Insight, we would
like to have switched to
the new Insight API.
And this is something that I
know, Jeremy, you've been
working a lot on trying to help
people and work with the
team so that we can actually
apply Insight at some point.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
I mean, like you said, you
were getting Jason or CSV
directly back, and you get to
specify only the parts you
want, not this message zip files
with all these CSVs you
have to kind of wade through
to find the right stuff.
TIM WINTLE: Yeah.
Like if you're on kind of a
cloud provider, or VPN, or
something, you're bandwidth is
quite kind of restricted by
the data that you're getting in,
then being able to really
compress the responses is
really good as well.
And luckily with YouTube
posting, a lot of so many
videos for people, you're
actually in a point where you
are worrying about this kind
of response size instead of
the size of a video file
that you would have
hosted 10 years ago.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
Great.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Well, all right.
So I think this is all the
time we have today.
Thank you very much
for visiting us.
Enjoy the rest of your trip here
in northern California.
And we will hopefully
see you soon again.
MATIAS MOLINAS: Thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you.
TIM WINTLE: Thank you.
JEREMY WALKER: Thanks Bye.